ok
today's leg of the journey finds me
rolling past the highest mountain in
northern Germany the Brocken I'm
surprised at how quickly I overcome the
400 meter rise in elevation it takes a
mere two hours whoo I've traveled a lot
since my last stop inventing order and
are completed more than a third of the
entire distance I've entered a new
German state now hessen to be exact I've
arrived in the primeval Reinhard's Bob
forest I've been on the road for 31 days
and have come nearly a thousand
kilometres from my start on suits only
around one and a half thousand to go and
49 days to do it in not exactly a
cakewalk now you're probably wondering
what I'm looking for in this forest
where there is no one around to be seen
anyway according to extensive online
research the oldest oak tree in Germany
browse around here it's 1500 e effort
the forests are responsible for this
stretch of woods is polite but firm my
information is faulty danki it was
around at the end of the Roman period
how can that be then pasion doesn't let
you live if your research isn't totally
accurate we believe the oak is 600 years
old or somewhere around 600 years old oh
children be warned don't always trust
what you read on the internet even so
this tree had seen plenty of history it
was alive when Knights and fair maidens
roamed these forests it was a strapping
sapling when Gutenberg invented the
printing press in the 15th century it's
also believed it was once a court oak
and that medieval trials took place
beneath its branches someone this old
has quite some girth as well
the span of my outstretched arms
measures 1 meter 88 that means it would
take four of me to encircle the trunk it
has a circumference of nearly eight and
a half meters
if you have to be headed this court oak
managed to survive for 600 years there's
been a lot of change and upheaval during
that time he dumb admit that it's not
back in the mid 19th century oaks played
an important role in helping to feed the
people here but took off any along and
the tree status as a court oak obviously
helped it survived for 600 years in the
vine hotspots Hadees XO Nagata my not so
long a valium interesting history but
why are the Oaks able to live as long as
they do I'd love to know the secret
yeah it's been Oaks former special kind
of wood the hardwood in the center of
the trunk which is especially resistant
to both insect pests and functions
excellent pizza
around a third of Germany is covered in
forests what although conditions are
improving for them trees are still under
threat studies show that over forty
percent of german oaks have diseases and
just thirty-seven percent of the trees
overall are in excellent health there
are seven billion trees in the country
that's 85 / inhabitants not only did
trees grow a lot older than we do they
outnumber us as well but I can do
something a plant can't I used to love
climbing tree as a kid looking around at
all this green I feel like doing it
again I will climb the tree of first
time 30 on your mark get set go
I used to be a little better at this
really I think what do you think well I
ever belong here in the forest home
Nicole that's a scary thought certainly
not in your red suit don't try this at
home then don't you dare time to turn my
back on the primeval forest and my nose
towards civilization I roll out of the
Reinhard's vault heading southeast to
another exciting destination the next
pun field stop on my German scooter
Odyssey
you